[Applause]
Andy how you doing good yeah very very
good
now speaking of good not to blow our own
horn or anything but our show has been
doing well it's been doing well and in
fact I don't know you're aware of this I
don't think they are at home in the
United States but this show is actually
shown now in Europe on something that's
called the super Channel and they've
been showing it on Europe for a couple
of months now mm-hmm
and I hear the show's doing quite well
over there we're a big sensation yeah
and then crazy furring land memphir
nerds just love it all right it's people
that understanding what the hell is who
are those clowns well anyway they they
sent me recently I think you're aware
they sent me to London recently to sort
of promote the show a bit over there
talk to some of the members of the
Foreign Press oh I'm aware cuz I didn't
get to go no it's not true yeah you were
invited but you had other things to do
other fish to fry is that that's true
all right and it was a lot of fun
actually and I did get I got one day off
they had my schedule was pretty packed I
had one day off in which to do some
sightseeing in London and so I brought a
camera crew with me and I thought I'd
record me trying to quickly I see
everything in London as best I could
well let's take a look thanks Andy I
needed that transition if you hadn't
said that we'd have read a book out here
sort of like Conan slideshow that's
right it's an action it's my chance to
pour everybody so I take a look at this
is my little trip I guess sightseeing in
London hi I'm in London England right
now I'm in town to promote late-night on
NBC's super channel they they show the
program over here and I got a bunch of
interviews things like that scheduled
for tomorrow and the next day but today
I have the data myself so I bought a
bunch of guide books and I'm gonna try
and see as much of London as I can in
one day it's not going to be easy but
I've never seen this city before I'm
really excited to be here so I'm gonna
try and do as much as I can hey cabbie
step on it will ya there's five Bob
for you
[Music]
to say
this is the Tower of London
it's where the crown jewels are kept
it's also the defensive fort for the old
city of London you can see it was a
pretty intimidating place to try and get
into these high stone walls these
ramparts these archers windows and then
this defensive strip of well manicured
lawn you know anyone who was gonna try
and get in there was gonna have to use a
comfortable walking shoe at the very
least I'm walking along the Thames and
right across the river you can see the
houses of parliament and right there is
Big Ben I've got some facts on Big Ben
it's so loud it can be heard for three
miles in either direction it takes 12
men to wash it every day and it weighs
over five tonnes
oh I'm sorry they're writing about
Fergie
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm I'm waiting here at the Hard Rock
Cafe here in London there's there's a
bit of a line here but I figure you know
how often to get a chance to go to the
Hard Rock
[Music]
I'm just gonna give it one more hour and
then then I'm going
this is exciting I'm in Piccadilly
Circus kind of like Times Square in New
York you got everything here you got the
theatres you got the restaurants statue
of Eros right up here which is you I'll
do that young kioss well anyway sort of
the whole city comes together right here
it's the heart
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I'm standing in front of Buckingham
Palace which to keep home of the royal
family it's actually very difficult to
get permission to shoot here but we got
around that we told him we were shooting
a porno flick no problem one of the
interesting things about Buckingham
Palace is you see these majestic gates
in front look at the insignia on the
front of the gate you see a lion on the
left and a horse on the right the lion
represents the everlasting power and
might of the British Empire and the
horse represents these things that the
English used to ride around on before
cars
[Music]
I'm grabbing lunch right now but I want
to make it quick because there's still a
ton of stuff I haven't seen yet in
London
Westminster Abbey Trafalgar Square st.
Paul's Cathedral no you know there's
bread really isn't very good hold on
[Music]
hello boss wah
could I have some bread please baguette
baguette young my way
[Music]
this isn't that good either I should
probably get back
TP the families but then movie sisters
so tips again a bar in the spot
[Music]
[Applause]
they're doing a great job of promotion
oh yeah
all right we're gonna take a little
break and then when we come back David
Hasselhoff is going to
[Applause]